no it just started as a side hustle like
i was in a basement in san francisco
that was like yo
i i have a theory about what i think
will be big
and i want to make 3 000 bucks a month
never was it like i want to make
millions of dollars or i want to have a
bunch of people or i want to have a
bunch of customers
[Music]
how are you sam how are you today i'm
good what are you doing well i just got
back from
albuquerque i was hanging out with my
family
and then uh i just got home and there's
like back-to-back meetings before we go
to the trail of lights tonight in austin
i know i neville and neil i've heard all
about you guys are going to have some
exciting times tonight did um
do you wait you weren't working today
like a normal schedule
uh i actually work really best in
airplanes
so i got up
worked in the airplane landed and just
been kind of back-to-back meetings now
until 6 30.
do you enjoy having a normal schedule
now
it um i had some trauma you know by the
way like silicon valley tech worker
trauma is like my boss didn't give me a
20 raise it was a 10 raise and i am
traumatized like when i worked at intel
all i did was meetings and it was like
and i was like this is the worst thing
ever and now i'm i'm in all i do is
meetings
[Music]
but then you know i will
i will say though today i was in some
meetings and i was interacting and i was
like man i love you people
there's some meetings where they suck
and you have to figure out how to get
rid of them or change the meeting and
there's somewhere it's like wow we're
business forward like there's things
that are happening that are making [__]
happen in the business so
noah you noah kagan's here
founder of this company called appsumo
which we'll talk about in a second but
you basically like you you kind of i
don't know do you say you stepped away
you weren't like actively running the
company day to day for like a couple
years
now you're the ceo again i so i was
active for a long time now i'm not
active
it's amazing it's the best i don't know
like i don't think i have it in me
at least not right now to go back and do
that
do you think that you have it in you
uh
it's hard it's it's
i mean i was not working i mean it
sounds such like an ass stuff but like i
wasn't really working i was doing
podcasts which isn't really working
and um
i was making a lot of money and now i'm
working i actually think i'll make the
least i've made this year wait what
what does that mean you're making a lot
of money from what well eamonn so we
hired this guy to run appsumo.com he was
running it and i was like oh well let me
make youtube videos and i'll do podcasts
and i'll like build send fox and
experimental stuff and then i would get
paid and then eamon wanted to step out
and uh to be an advisor and i stepped in
and now i'm having to do all his work i
will say
and then yeah i think i'll make less
money this year two things with that one
sometimes when you criticize another
because i criticize damon a lot
um but just like productive just like
you could be better you could be better
yeah like jewish why are you doing this
yeah yeah jewish mother like noah
why not your your cousin
so
you could have been like your brother
he's a doctor
and uh
um
one under being in his shoes definitely
makes me uh respect him so much more but
just a lot just a lot like he is a very
impressive guy also get a deal with me
but i'd say the second thing is that um
the work now is harder it's hard
but it's much more rewarding and so i
was even writing that down in my diary
this morning i said dear diary hard work
is rewarding
noah you have the weirdest so like
you talk about having a diary you always
talk about going to therapy which is no
big deal these these all these things
are great but you act like a tough guy
sometimes and then you talk about like
uh oh you got to complain to your diary
you kind of
i think you know
i think of myself like a chinese dish
i'm like sweet and sour pork you know
like you're not really supposed to have
pork as a jew and then sometimes it's
sweet and then sometimes you're like
kind of sour
it's just like it's a it's a mixed bag
it's a variety it's uh entertaining
you're uh
since i've known you now for i think
like eight or nine years and you've all
you're
you're cagey with numbers so i don't
want to push you if you don't want to be
pushed can you talk about how big you
guys are now
given i mean in your youtube video i
think you said 100 million in revenue
yeah we're not going to hit it we
actually missed our goal this year um
it's going to be less than that
it's weird
you said 80 in another video what i
think
because someone doesn't want to tell you
how much they make as a cage
um
yes
i don't think that's wrong though i
don't like talk i don't talk about a lot
of stuff either i say like round numbers
sometimes or i'll just say i don't want
to talk about that all right how much
did you sell the hustle for
let's try these let's try kg numbers
um
tens of millions of dollars uh
yeah i mean how much do you make a year
now working at hubspot
well i get paid uh i got i get paid a
whole lot of stock but my base salary i
think is only 250 000 maybe
only
well my stock is is significant
i will say this is you know in all these
shows nowadays and crypto people they're
always like this is not financial less
i'm gonna give financial advice i buy a
lot of hubspot stock i think it's one of
the most undervalued stocks on the
market so dude by the way when they
bought us i think it was um they were
worth 17 billion dollars or 16 billion
dollars in late january around when they
bought us i think today it's 40. so
yeah that's gone up a lot so and that's
why when people ask how much we sold for
i'm like well we sold we i basically i
got tens of millions in cash and then i
also got hubspot stock but it's already
it's it's up significantly since we sold
so and i don't know like what price do
you say and
yeah sorry
i don't know and i don't love exactly
saying where are we gonna ask who's
wealthier you or sean oh dude i don't i
don't know i i hear i'll tell you this
we did a podcast we did a podcast
recently and i basically said my goal
was to make at least 20 million dollars
by the age of 30. and i did that
dude good for you and that was the goal
but
you know like i i also don't i own
assets now in the in some real estate
and i own
um
hubspot stock and airbnb stock but like
you own appsumo which
an 80 million dollar your business
do you think you're worth two or three
hundred million dollars
um
i think epsom is worth somewhere between
a quarter billion and a billion dollars
isn't that crazy uh
yeah i don't really
look at that as part of my net worth i
just look at my own
it's interesting we've talked about this
a little bit like i think there's
silicon valley entrepreneurs that think
about your valuation of a company and
then there's me and you who are normal
people that are like what's your profit
what's your revenue all right you're
worth a million not like oh well the
multiple is this if they say multiple
they're silicon valley
well uh i mean you guys would sell for
if you're if you're if you think you're
if you said that you're going to do in
the range of 80 million in revenue i
mean i don't know how i would value that
five times profits or five times that
number i guess right
i don't know man it's a it's a little
surreal i and i don't i'm not sure how
different my life would be my brother
did ask me he's like if you were to sell
you know how much would you sell for
and i was like i don't know like if it
was a billion that's like and i think
people don't realize that like when mark
zuckerberg i worked at facebook and i
heard uh catherine's like shut up
talking about that but you got to give
him credit man he turned down a billion
dollar offer at 24. yeah he's crazy like
dude you took the first offers anyone
offered you
no i didn't but but like yeah it was
like eager i mean i think i said i would
love i say that with love dude no we we
we had a few other ones but it was a
good one and i knew that hubs i didn't
know i was betting that hubspot stock
was a good buy and i think that
i just like i'm not zuck i i i can't
imagine
working
dude he gets do you think his life is
enjoyable i can't imagine it's enjoyable
no i mean i guess he enjoys it but i i
just think that that's hell to me that's
why he has to have a virtual character
enjoy it more for him yeah i don't know
i mean like
we have you and i have this buddy we
remember that one time we were out to
eat and
you could say i don't know you're he's
your friend so you could tell me if you
want to say his name but he was like
noah you're not growing at three times a
year what the [__] you're leaving so
much on the table and you're like dude i
just went mountain biking like on a
tuesday and then on wednesday i like did
this and then on thursday i did this
we're gonna make like 80 million in
revenue this year and i own most of it
i'm so happy and he was criticizing you
as a friend and uh
and i was like
no is he is he crazy like you you got it
this is perfect this is don't change
this is perfect
it's um i i don't know
i guess how you want to live do you
think that i guess that changes over the
years
right and i think what what's that
no no how you want to live i mean i
think in your 20s you're just like
scrambling and wanting to i know for me
i wanted to prove myself i wanted to
have status i wanted to have it and then
as your 30s you know i'm still doing it
no i'm just like you know you you figure
out more what really gives you
fulfillment i think everyone's got their
own stuff i think figuring it out for
yourself is a really tough thing
you um how many people work there 100
i think now we have 140
isn't that crazy
it's
yeah
yeah it is crazy do you like it it was
just started as a side oh sorry am i
cutting you off dude no keep going i
want to hear from you i just started as
a side hustle like i was in a basement
in san francisco that was like yo
i i have a theory about what i think
will be big
and i want to make 3000 bucks a month
never was it like i want to make
millions of dollars or i want to have a
bunch of people or i want to have a
bunch of customers
why three thousand a month
a thousand was for living a thousand was
for eating and a thousand was for saving
that's funny that's almost exactly what
i did too it was about that number um
did you well how big do you think it was
going to get
i never thought that far ahead
i mean there's a go for it
i keep interrupting you i'm sorry go
ahead that's all good man well like
there's a there's a quote i read by paul
graham and it was like if you're so
worried about what's gonna your
company's gonna be in 10 years like
you're never going to make sure you can
take care of your customers today and
your business won't exist in 10 years so
don't worry about it
and i just kind of i guess that's how
that's that's served me well i think
someone asked me they're like what did
it take to become a millionaire and i
think one of the things for me was just
like following the curiosity
and i was like curious about all the
stuff that like that we me and you get
paid for
yeah i mean i'm in the same boat i think
when i having 140 employees would
i don't know if it would freak me out
but like
i remember do you still look at your
payroll when you pay it every two weeks
well so do you want to just tell you the
call i literally that's why i was late
to the podcast yeah because i'm you know
we're we're taking the whole team out to
costa rica
and then
we're also
we're it was some spend for advertising
it was like 50 000 and i'm just like
yes we make revenue but at the end of
the day if you don't have income and
you're not a funded business you're
gonna go out of business and so
i think it's figuring out how do you
create you know checks and balances so
i'm not stressing about it weekly but
there's definitely some net income
issues that
are keeping me up and then we're doing
budgeting projections and the [__] up
things budgeting is if you budget for
100 million to 120 million whatever 150
and you spend on that and you don't make
it then yeah you get kind of [__] too
i think that you and i are similar in
that like when when i see the so i'll
like say yeah i want to i think we can
hit 100 million in revenue and then they
say all right well then we have to spend
80 million dollars and i look at it and
i'm like
oh my god what the hell what is this 50
000 expense what is this 10 000 expense
are you crazy we can't do this this is
ridiculous and i get fearful i think
that's the cool thing about having a guy
like amen where he's a little bit less
attached
this company called nerdwall you know
nerdwallet yeah
tim chen uh gave me a little bit of
money to start the hustle and it was his
idea to give me money he was like hey
can i give you some money to start this
and uh i took it and they just went
public at like three or four billion in
valuation and i went to him one day i go
tim we're spending 80 000 a month in
expenses we're making more than that but
like that's crazy he goes man it's just
an excel number like it's just an it's
just it's a spreadsheet
you it has an input and an output that's
all you should care about you shouldn't
actually care that it's 80 thousand
dollars a month and i still find myself
freaking out over that stuff and so for
you let's say i don't i don't know i
imagine your payroll is like
10 40 50 million dollars a year or
something like that or your payroll and
marketing expenses i would i flip out
when i think about that because that's
all
basically your money whereas with amen
or someone else you could be you could
be more detached yeah i mean eamonn
always cared and eamon i have a lot of
respect and admiration for him and he's
still very involved i i think the way
that i've tried to approach it generally
is two pieces number one when does the
red flag need to be triggered so every
week we have a monday kpi sheet that
they update our gross margin they update
like customers and so there's color
coding and it's like okay are there red
flags in any of the numbers that i need
to call [__] on
and
i think that
that obviously reduces your anxiety and
it helps you make sure that you're
trusting but verifying i think the
second thing around it is that
how much if something is a profitable
spend how much should you spend it
depends on it all depends on a lot of
different stuff but if you're spending
money and you're making 30 profit go all
in
hunt there's no budget it's unlimited
and i think that's part of the question
with the spending for me is that
where is our spending very profitable
like is it in marketing is in
development is in sales is it in the
partner success team or is there things
like that that should be more like aws
where they're they're a little bit more
scalable up and down
and they're not as profitable so we need
to be mindful of that how big do you
think this business could get in like 10
or 20 years do you have do you ever
think about that i'm just trying to
survive to next year dude
i mean you know it's funny we've had as
we've grown
and it's been interesting because i have
my youtube channel which is a very small
team of like five people and then we
have appsumo which is a larger thing
i come back to the why right like on
appsumo it's very simple we promote dope
tools at great prices and we help people
start and grow online businesses
appsumo.com
and um
i think we have to come back to that
because we were like we're gonna be in
five years i'm like probably helping
people grow and start online businesses
no i know you're going to be doing the
same thing but like the revenue was i
mean we were yeah we
we went to the spreadsheet and we
tripled numbers silicon valley double
double triple triple from in and out
and uh we became a billion dollar
company revenue in like five years or
something like that
i i think right now
candidly some of our
mechanics in terms of the scalable
business means as we add partners do we
get customers and this business grow
um
the
how do i sit more clearly it's just not
adding up like we added more partners
this year and the proportional amount of
customers did not come with that and so
we have to work a little bit more on
that flywheel which is well i think that
you must
with trends so we had trends our
subscription service we [__] crushed
it during coven we crushed it and i
think
now sales slow down a little bit i think
it's cyclical but in this the like i bet
if i had a bet covid was like the best
times you ever had um
cope was great man i thought it was just
great in general right i thought it
brought there's a lot of good about
cover just about humanity and not the
death part maybe but like the bringing
people closer
i don't know man i've been doing the
internet [__] since 2004
i've never had a recession
and it's not that i have some superpower
but it's like well the only way to not
have recession is just keep doing things
that people want
and basically i think one of the other
key things to kind of consider is how do
you have discipline when times are good
so you don't have to be as disciplined
when times are bad and i think right now
candidly with appsumo i think we're
being a little bit undisciplined with
our spending and our hiring because
times have been better and i'm trying to
get that a little bit more tighter
whether the you know the future is good
or not
why is your youtube team so big five
people i don't even think it's that big
mr beast is like 100 people
no way you think he has 100 employees at
least 50 full-time at least 50 full-time
100 contractors yeah
and are they what's his name the mr
beast jimmy jimmy are they all like
it's cause it's like the jimmy show
right so it's like whatever he wants you
do
i think that'd be weird to have 50
employees where it's like hey guys next
week i'm thinking i want to do this the
reason i would hate that is because then
you've got someone like hey jimmy what
if we had a rolling stone song in the
background no i don't want that just
like let me do what i want to do please
just like
fulfill that it's a so we have a head of
staff
and one thing i've never one thing i
hate i hate when someone's like hey can
you remind me about this and i'm like no
[__] just write it down i just told you
you want me to remind you like do your
job
but i will say you know becoming ceo
which i never called myself over the
years until recently
and uh is that
there is times you're like yo remind me
and you're like oh my god you're gonna
remind me her name's anna who's head of
staff she's phenomenal and then with the
youtube channel i'm like hey i want you
to come back with more ideas come go
pitch me 10 more ideas go go and they
come back i'm like this is the best ever
and so i think it is figuring out you
know what areas you like to play in and
then being around people that you're
just consistently impressed with
but having people that'll do help you
figure out [__] oh god it's epic
are you getting noticed on the street
now
no not
just really you don't
it varies in austin you know it's kind
of our hometown so i think more people
do it um
not not actually not even though the
channel's gotten bigger we doubled this
year i actually used to get noticed a
lot at the gym
the guy hey bro i'm like
hey i don't know i'm always still
excited when people came to come and say
hi
i just got uh did you get recognized
yeah weekly i just this like this
morning just walking down the street and
uh it makes me a little nervous
sometimes because i'm like thinking i
gotta like uh
like like
like uh i love smoking cigars and i'll
just walk around smoking cigars and i'm
like i don't want people to see me
smoking
it makes me a little nervous
don't you think it's flattering i'm
always so i always feel honored that
like i feel like i've worked on yeah
something i've worked on has impacted
this person and
they're excited to to say hi to me like
who who have you seen that you've said
hi to that you're a little nervous the
other day i saw logan paul and i and i
and i respect logan paul and i said
what's up and i just i just pounded and
i go and i just pounded it while i was
walking by she's huge drew logan's huge
was this year
new york when i was in or i guess it
wasn't the other day about two or three
months ago i saw him and i and i respect
it i respect what he built and he was a
big old dude and i i i could have
stopped and be like hey like this is
what i do for a living your brother was
on my thing and i probably we probably
got friends of friends but i was
honestly kind of nervous and i just like
just pounded it when i walked away well
you i'm sure i'll do a twitter thing
like hey i want to have logan on the
show but anyways that's that's awesome
man did you see my twitter thread about
when i met the silk road guy
no
you didn't see that i posted it the
other day i was looking through old
dropbox pictures and um
or go to my instagram or something
you'll see it
and uh i posted your yeah i want you to
see it it's me with ross albright the
guy from silk road oh i think i remember
that story you posted about it
yeah i talked about it like here but i
was looking through old dropbox pictures
and i found the pictures of us together
and i originally took them down off
facebook because i was nervous but now
it's no big deal and i posted the
pictures about how i met this guy named
ross at a party
and we just chit-chatted and
he got arrested like a
months later and i know i recognized him
and i was like oh my god that was ross
the guy we hung out with at the party
how much better is your life now being
rich it
did you you know that 70 thousand dollar
um that 70 000 study i've heard that it
sounds like [__] to me it's [__]
it's way better it's way better it's
significantly better
it's significantly better i think like
i still worry about stuff and i was just
talking to my friend about this today
and i was like why am i nervous about
this and that i told neville i go
neville get neville bought this 800
vacuum and i was like i went to up to
his house to borrow it and i was like i
can't buy one of these it's 800 it's too
expensive and he's like why are you
worrying about that i'm like i don't
know it freaks me out i'm afraid to buy
stuff
so
do you have that yeah well i think two
things are interesting one i went to the
grocery store i was with my parents you
know for thanksgiving
my mom we get grapes i really into green
grapes lately and she's like noah these
are really expensive today let's not get
them i'm like deborah
it's your birthday i'm going to treat
you you get two of them
so i don't i have no problems anything
that's health related i'll buy i don't
know
i'm still mindful of it i think what's
fascinating on the other side of it sam
is like i mentioned it to you on text
but you didn't want me to talk about it
which is like crypto and nft crap
which all these you know former shopify
store owners now are crypto experts
which is funny
and um
i like trade and i'll make or i'll buy
something and make like a hundred
dollars or i'll lose like a thousand and
i'm like not devastated but what's the
same they're like appsumo like we
promote partners and you know we'll do
like a million dollars in a day and the
partners make like 700 000 and our
customers are happy and i'm like well
that's cool yeah it's it's funny there's
a phrase it's called a a penny poor
pound rich i think right or uh yeah
something like that do
do you uh
we're talking about crypto but you don't
actually buy crypto right you just
bought a bunch at one time and you held
on to no well two things one thing i
want to highlight this is a phrase that
chad said my business partner at
appsumo.com you like how i plug it um he
actually had this phrase that was great
he's like noah don't confuse the ant
hills for the mountains
i was like damn that's good and he's
like when we're doing work at appsumo
and you know the different products
we've built or you know whatever it is
he's like
is this a macro thing or a micro thing
and let's do the macro thing let's get
some [__] mountains man he's like
don't sweat this [__] stuff and i'm
like all right but that's hard man
especially i i was telling someone
recently where
there's all these productivity tools
and everyone's all these everyone's
always like what's the latest pretty i'm
like you're not even doing anything
like don't worry about the calendar and
the productivity tool worry about just
doing important things this is the best
productivity tool the back of an
envelope
that's damn
it's a good that gets the job done oh my
crypto thing yeah i buy i'm a boring
investor so i think there's active
income and passive income and i try to
focus on my active
so i just started buying in 2015 and i
just put it on autopilot and i just auto
bought it every month for the past six
years and it's like made up of a
substantial
i mean you've you've done well with it i
think which is pretty great i'll tell
you the number on that that i don't mind
well okay i mean you can i don't have to
tell you it's fine
i if i had a bet can i can i guess oh
yeah or i'll be kg i would guess between
one and two million
not four million but
it's four million
yeah
isn't that nuts
i well it's always so funny because then
you're like yesterday i was this weekend
i was like disappointed i didn't buy
crypto punks when my buddy was like you
should buy it buy it dude but it was
like 50 000 and i'm like that's [__]
crazy to buy status and imagery and like
it's an investment it's only investment
when it goes up it's gambling when it
goes down
well the nfts i think are mostly [__]
stupid
oh don't get me started dude i just went
on a deep hole
are you on board or not
dude i just got scammed i lost my i'm
like
i can't i don't even know what happened
for the past two weeks i'm like
yesterday i woke up at 8 am to buy apes
i just spent 1600 on apes
what of the of the 4 million in crypto
how much did you what's your what's your
basis there um i could pull it up it's
probably
maybe about half a million or four
hundred thousand isn't that amazing is
it is that crazy uh yeah well i think
i've always just it's interesting
because i've always not always when i
started using it i was like oh i can see
why this is going to be big
um but yeah the return on it as an
investment is pretty insane
that's nuts
what else and like what else could do
that like some public equity
equities uh but you don't even angel
invest do you i mean angel invest could
do that it just takes forever
yeah it's not i mean i think the best
investment for everyone is their own
business
so if you look at it like active income
like really creating your own company
has pretty much the highest multiples i
can imagine also you can control it if
you can get something to work because
most of them don't work that well yeah
but you got to grind sometimes
often
i talked to this guy i was biking on
saturday
and this guy named nick he's like man i
got a grind and i was like how much do
you i was like how much does he make he
makes he's like 60k and i was like why
don't you you know it doesn't i don't
care i'm not judging him how much it's
like but if you're gonna grind at least
grinding something has higher upside for
yourself because it's the same amount of
work like he doesn't work harder than me
i don't work harder than him i just
worked on something that from a strictly
financial perspective has a better
opportunity when you're working with
eamonn so eamonn uh
is uh was your ceo good friend my good
friend too when
how often would you talk to him
it varied like it varied probably like
once a week on fridays
and then one a little bit throughout the
week but they actually kept me out of
slack they kept me out of everything
because it's kind of like a
noise like my mom's a jewish mother it's
like noah what's that on the screen what
is that it's better to be out
and i think that's probably the reason
he wanted to step out and this is i
don't think we're airing our private
stuff wait he wants to step out because
you were nagging him
yeah i think to some extent i don't
think anyone feels really excited no one
wakes up like excited you know unless
it's some weird kink
uh to be like hey oh what are you doing
today and i think there's probably a
little bit too much of that
uh do you think that
i mean i have i've had people quit for
that reason i do the same thing you and
i are very similar you know that right
and uh
and i did the same thing where i'm like
why are you doing this what's going on
today what are you doing right now today
like what actions can we take
immediately to fix x y and z
and i think you need both you need that
urgency but like if you have a good if
you have a winner you do gotta let them
chill and get it done
um
do you think that eamonn whenever i have
hired people to run stuff i always i get
i freak out i'm like this guy's gonna
when he finds out that i'm like
profiting off their work like they're
gonna bail this is so unfair and i hope
they don't figure this out did you freak
out about that
i used to have a lot of that where i
never would post anything on social same
like i wouldn't post any activity i
wouldn't post like my you know our
youtube videos like hell i made my first
million like i would never say [__]
about that and eventually
uh i got to a point where i was like
well am i helping these people do their
best lives at the company or what i can
am i do my best to pay them whatever
they want so like with eamon i'm not
going to share his numbers but i asked
him i was like how much do you want to
make and he said numbers and he made
more than that
and so i never really felt this never
felt guilt because that guy got more
than he wanted and i got well too
but i think within the company it's also
people are free to work wherever so it's
like how do you create an environment
that people are like yo that guy's doing
well and i'm doing well
are you interested in any projects right
now you had send fox did you shut down
send fox
uh no we're still writing send fox.com
it's a mailchimp alternative
um what do you like what type of
projects are keeping you up the two
things that i'm i mean number one is
appsumo so you know becoming more of a
marketplace so
you buy or sell software tools books and
then the second stuff is like all this
nft stuff is mind-blowing
there's just so much so sam i think like
you you kind of smirk
and you know i
at first i think that's what a lot of
people have done with it
the same with crypto when i was buying
in 2015 we were like i don't i don't
fully get it
but there's something just interesting
same when i joined facebook when i
joined facebook you were like you're
gonna go work at a social network okay
same you know it seems weird but there's
just a lot of these really interesting
use cases that
uh i'm very tempted and i'm very excited
about right what use cases
so some of the really interesting ones
one is called city dao so basically
everyone pulls their money
and then they buy a city so they bought
land in wyoming and now if you own one
of the nfts or tokens within it you get
votes to what they're going to do with
the city
so i find i find that really fascinating
plus everything's public so you see
who's voting you see what the votes are
there's not much hidden
there's other ones
that i've liked one's called head dow
it's kind of a stupid-ass one i think
conceptually it's really interesting i
don't know if it's run well
um but what i like about it is
it is a
uh fund where you buy their nfts so
there's ten thousand everyone buys an
nft and if you hold the nfts
um and the fund goes and buys stuff and
based on your nft you get some return
for whatever the the fund invests in so
it's kind of like a index fund of crypto
and other assets
so i think there's just something
what's the city one called
city dao
the who's who's organizing it
city dow i don't know but it's all
public for the most part but there's
just there's so much stuff like that
like think about this you can do housing
so like right now housing is like noah
owns a contract goes to the thing and
all this well it's like you can have a
house that's shared by a thousand people
or like roblox or minecraft and the game
stuff is really interesting where it's
like there's not like facebook and
twitter that get everything or roblox
it's like the creators and the consumers
own the whole thing
same with appsumo like how can we create
it so the whole customer base owns
appsumo so they're incentivized even to
start doing apps more i guess it's kind
of like owning a share in amazon but
kind of on a deeper level are you have
you ever like paid money to be part of
like a membership group
like uh tiger21 or anything like that
not yet i've always
not yet so there's this thing called uh
what's it called friends with benefits
have you seen that i've heard of it what
is this and so i think the market cap is
like hundreds of millions at this point
and so it was basically a a soho house
online so like cool new york young
people
paid either 500 or a thousand or two
thousand dollars to be part of an online
group that held meetups and it was like
hot people and [__] young people
wearing vans and supreme and [__] like
cool kid [__]
and
it was uh
you know you had to buy
an nft or a coin to join the
the community
and you're incentivized to make the
community awesome because
people could sell their membership or
like give it up
and it could be worth more than when
they initially bought in that and i
think that's
interesting
there's just a lot of you i mean it's
still so early so what's gonna
like what's gonna like after the dust
settles and the consolidation of all the
junk because i'll tell you i jumped in
there's all this discord
discord you know it's like slack for
juvenile delinquents dude it's so hard
to figure out i feel so old
it's not just that it's just hard to use
and then it's just like so spammy like i
go in it and they're like
there's just a lot going on in the space
and so trying to
try not to rush into anything but just
understand like all right i think
appsumo we did a good job where people
are like i want to start businesses i
want tools and it's like how is
entrepreneurship and startups and stuff
evolving and there's definitely
something where there's so much money
and there's so much speed being
happening in this crypto nft space
um that i find just i don't know at this
current time i'm like obsessed with the
guy or the people setting up the town in
wyoming how are they going to make a
profit how did they get paid so there's
a lot of different dude there's all
these different i fully don't understand
every single one out there um i'm not
biology
but
what they do is a few different things
so one they could keep some of the
assets so when they so they do a few
different things when you mint
the tokens or the nfts to give out
you people buy into it so when i create
the baseball cards and i sell it to you
it's like one each each
to for you to buy i the the city dow
keeps all that and then they could
decide how much of that goes out
to use to buy land they could say 80
buys land or 50 they can decide that the
second thing they do which is really
interesting this is what's really clever
about nft stuff is a lot of times on the
secondary sales the original owner gets
a cut
you know that
yeah i didn't know how much though
so it varies so you can have a thing
where if i create nfts and it's ever
resold i get five percent of all sales
forever
so there's just some there's some really
interesting things and then you can have
people contribute more
uh there's just a lot of variations and
look in the end of the day people have
had partnerships so this is not brand
new i think the the medium of exchange
through crypto and all this stuff is
creating new new opportunities
you you and neville and a couple other
friends went and hung out with peter
thiel a few weeks ago and you could
decide what you want to publicize or not
but one thing that i think i can say is
um i think he said this to neville or
something where he was like you know
businesses are are neat but they die
and he said something like a city
any city that's ever been a somewhat
major city it's never died before
and apparently his obsession right now
is on cities
uh and i actually invested in this one
company where they're doing uh gene
editing you know what gene editing is
not familiar it's like basically the the
kind of explain like i'm five version is
if you get a disease and your skin like
goes away or something happens to your
skin and it gets messed up gene editing
you can tinker with someone's genes and
it will grow they'll grow back new skin
whereas before they probably wouldn't
have
the issue with gene editing is that it's
highly regulated by the fda and so like
the future of gene editing could be like
if you're an amputee you can grow back a
new leg or or you could grow a new liver
or kidney or whatever you know [__] like
that and peter thiel has this city in
like bolivia somewhere in central or
south america and he basically is like
the founder of this city and this
company that i invested in is based out
of that city because there is no fda in
that city which is like potentially
horrible but it's kind of interesting
he said that he's in he's incredibly
invested and interested in new cities
and uh i think so i think that's cool
when i hear about all these new startup
people like mark laurie the founder of
jet he has the new cities i think these
new cities are actually incredibly
fascinating yeah i uh i'm i'm more
interested in kind of like shared home
ownership
i think there's something just kind of
clever like
how do i own a building but there's a
lot of people that own it a lot of
people can use it i think there's just
like too many people that have too much
house for just one individual
so i like the the concept of that what
do you think about meeting peter thiel
you know what was it there's a lot of
interesting things about him um
i think one i tweeted about this at no
kagan was that his he just uses like an
iphone 7 right like the guy's like what
are we on now what i've got the new one
what is that yeah 13 pro.5 whatever and
he's on a seven
yeah and he had like you know crappy ass
new balances he looked like he was
wearing like mervyn socks and like you
know like
wrangler jeans i gotta give a [__] about
it and you know was he really do you
think he was wearing regular jeans
wrangler
just like nor like kate mart jeans
just like normal and you know but he
also had three security guards and you
know cameras and they checked the
building all that kind of stuff
i think i admired that he is a thinker
and it made me appreciate you know i met
him when i worked at facebook and i
still remember this story he like bought
into our poker game and then he had to
go meet with zuck and then he lost and
then he's like hey can i get my money
back and then boz who's now like the cto
was like [__] no
yeah
yeah peter did and i was like can't
believe that also we would say no the
guy who's the only you know the main
investor at the time
uh
i think the other thing that i
appreciate about how much how much was
the buy-in like 10 bucks and he asked
for it back yes there's money but i was
like what are you doing dude like i i
was kind of surprised he wanted it back
but then i like that boss like [__] you
he
said that exactly like that he said [__]
you no no no he just was like no and
then the funny thing about that i i like
busted out
uh i don't know i mean like 20 minutes
later
and i go outside and his like half a
million dollar mclaren is sitting
outside
i was like all right all right what did
you tell him that do you remind him of
that story when you're with him recently
i don't think he remembers me um but
yeah i think the second thing about him
is that he's a very i was just looking
at my notes of him i don't mind sharon i
think just like he he's just a deep
thinker
it just felt like this guy's like really
like him and this is another you know
him and like keith boy and all these
guys they're a lot of history readers
they're like deep ass like reading
boring [__] books about 1900 history
that i just won't i'm not won't i just
don't do and i think that gives that's
where a lot of their advantage comes
from so ben who's on this podcast has
this podcast that's on history and he
just talks about historical figures and
he does a biography on them it's
incredibly fascinating and right before
you came on we did a whole podcast on
history and how
um you could just learn you could learn
you basically could just not make the
mistakes that other people have made
just from reading about them so it's
kind of interesting uh keith or boy i
don't know keith or boy other than
twitter dude he comes off like such a
jerk on twitter i don't know if i want
to hang out with him but i definitely
would want to meet uh peter thiel dude
he's a legend i love me keith boy him
david sachs oh i don't listen to all in
show
um
i don't even know is he is he cool keith
is sharp
keith doesn't really respond to me he he
doesn't respond to me as much anymore
because i've been trying to get him on
my show
uh on the no kagan show and um but he's
just [__] bright man like the guy's
very bright i think he's very astute i
also like people that have like i think
lately i'm more considerate
and i like when he's at a level of
wealth in the hundreds of millions that
it's just like [__] and he's like yo
that guy's a dumb ass san francisco's
[__] i think this is crying i have a
lot of admiration for anyone who hasn't
i like that too i just think that you
could do it i don't think that you need
to be polite all the time i'm an [__]
too i just think that like when you are
a boss and you're a winner and you maybe
pick on the weak ones publicly in a in a
rude and abrupt way it makes you look
weak and soft
and like a bully and i think that
i that's how i don't like how it comes
off online but whenever i have seen
interviews with him he seems incredibly
kind
not kind but
polite i don't know i mean i think i
guess i also agree with his opinions so
i don't mind his approach like he's like
liz warbin sucks
miami's the best here's like businesses
that i'm
um you know really bullish on
you like miami i'm more neutral to it i
haven't spent enough time it seems
appealing like there's i really wanted
to go to art basel like that's on a
bucket list man to see all the cool art
and nft and just like the vibe
uh i'm not i think every city's got
every everyone has a calling when they
get into a city miami's never called me
to live there when i visit but it's
enjoyable would you stay i do intend to
stay in austin for a while yeah i think
it's also you if you ever feel like
stuck in life like i was feeling a
little flat and like frustrated with a
lot of work [__] going on and
you know i don't know i wanted pity
party and i think to take you know to
take a power party and you got to get
the [__] out so like i was in
albuquerque last week i'm going to go to
cabo this weekend gonna go to the bay or
in la in a few weeks i think you can get
the [__] out sometimes and just change
geography so tell me about peter thiel
what do your notes say
i would okay here's a shocker this is
shocked me sam if you had five he's
probably worth like 10 billion
i was like peter how much are you
spending on longevity
and he's like almost nothing what that's
crazy i would like that's spent
everything on that i was like dude drop
a bill give me a billion i'll solve it
so he doesn't spend anything on
longevity he spends very little he's
like i do
oh i don't know how to say some of this
stuff he does some stuff like male
things to help but like
very like i thought he would be like
yeah i have scientists on staff and i
have an institute and i'm like
you know the other thing is i was like
oh do you have a crazy diet and he's
like
he's like none of that really is going
to move the needle dramatically he's
like i i eat dark choc i eat chocolate
cake at night
like he was telling us how his assistant
hides food from him so he doesn't eat it
when he travels like you think the guy
who's like this genius which he is is
like
hyper disciplined he's like no i'm not
but he also knows he's not so he
accommodates so i i think i was just
shocked that he's not doing more
longevity you know we talked about um on
the podcast we talked about this guy
named brian johnson who started
braintree and he's like a billionaire
guy now and he's got a whole website
where you can look at where he's
spending millions of dollars a year on
his on longevity and you can go to his
website and look at all the stuff that
he's doing and it's incredibly
fascinating and when i saw that i'm like
this is exactly what you should do if
you're if you're that wealthy and i'm
amazed that peter thiel doesn't do that
yeah that was shocking i was shocked
that he had low willpower he talked you
know because you kind of you watch all
these [__] videos and you listen to
podcasts like i wake up at five and i
have you know celery and i take a cold
shower he's like nah i like eating
chocolate cake
and he's you know and he was drinking
wine and like he eat carbs and i was
like he's a [__] human which made me
have a lot of appreciation for him and i
i mean and i felt like he also was very
generous way more than i thought he
stayed and talked to us the whole time
like four hours without checking his
phone without
tweeting any [__] and was very
present which i really appreciated i
read this book with him in ryan holiday
and ryan holiday said something really i
thought cool about him where he said
basically if you ask him a question
he'll say well you know some people
believe this
other people think that it's this this
and this
like he like
looks at uh he looks at all sides and he
doesn't actually always tell his opinion
it's an interesting thought um
i think one of the things he had a lot
of phrases do you want to hear from
these like he just had these phrases i'm
like man these are great phrases
look ahead function
i thought that was good what's that mean
uh basically like how are you looking
when you're thinking about a decision
how are you looking ahead to what the
outcome could be
i thought that was really clever like
how much are you thinking further ahead
on things
uh zombification
he's like everyone is a dumbass there's
no everyone has like the same thoughts
he's like i'm looking for anyone who has
unique thoughts
um
incremental versus monumental shifts
that's a baller one that's a really good
one um
companies are mortal cities are immortal
yeah i was i was thinking about that and
we i was talking to neville he goes yeah
peter told me about this and he uh and i
was like yeah i think that's true and i
was trying to think of like a city in
america that has like just gone away and
one that was at least
a mediocre city and there's nothing hmm
well i think the thing that i never
thought of that he had i was like whoa
that's so interesting like we think of
cities is like um
he was trying to talk about how cities
you're kind of like a shareholder of a
country
and i never thought about that he's like
you can you know remote work is the
worst thing that can happen to cities
did he have an opinion about that yeah
he thinks places like california
francisco are people can vote now with
their feet and so the ability to work
remote now hurts them
um
yeah
and and i agree with that but doesn't he
live in l.a yeah yeah that's kind of
weird right i i admire that i think i
get annoyed with people like i'm in
puerto rico to save ford nichols and i'm
like well yeah but you have to puerto is
actually not horrible but you have to
live there yeah there's no [__] power
for two weeks if there's a hurricane and
look there's dude you're on the beach
there's i love mexican food it's got
margaritas it's got a good life but
the other side of that is like is that
how much is it worth to live a
sub-optimal life and i admire that he's
like [__] it i'm in l.a i'm going to
live baller
um even whatever tax rate this is i read
that in that same book what's that ryan
holiday book it's awesome do you want to
tell you or not tell you no conspiracy
or
conspiracy theories or something yeah
that's it
that was just conspiracy theory is that
it conspiracy um he's in that book he
said that wherever peter thiel goes 24
hours a day he's got a black mercedes
waiting for him oh that that's what was
outside the car that was outside the
restaurant was it a black mercedes yeah
yeah he had a disco ball inside it was
crazy and he and i i think i'm almost
positive he says it's running at all
times he tells me they have to have it
running
that's really interesting in the book
that's what he said uh he goes he has a
mercedes form all the time and uh
apparently he's got like some residence
or something in new zealand where uh i
think there's also a jet waiting for him
uh like in a close vicinity wherever
he's going and he goes just in case if
anything bad happens he could bolt to
new zealand
i think the question that i'm curious
that you got me thinking about for
myself or for you or for the audience is
that if we had a billion dollars how
would we live differently
what do you think you do
you still want to do stuff right like
you still want to work like work is fun
people are like oh it's like dude sit
around all day see how that goes
[__] boring it's [__] lame um not
too much i think i would just do the
things i'm doing at a higher level now i
would like not worry about buying houses
i'm not sure dude i don't know the
absolute stuff is hard
i don't think i would pay right away to
get out of it but i'd try to figure some
something else it's it's tough i got
another like year or two in it for this
this role
uh then probably buy houses and i'm just
trying to figure out how to adjust the
work to only do the area i want i would
accumulate large amounts of land and i
would create nice residents on all of
them so me and my friends can just go
and
like it's so rare that
we can go someplace and do whatever we
want
and that's exciting for me like that's
what we we should do do we have any
friends that have lots of land that we
can go and shoot guns and drive
motorcycles and [__] and just be like 12
year olds that's what i'm talking about
i thought we were gonna say i was really
hoping sam our answers would be like you
know i would take that billion dollars
and give it out to the world
well i'm not giving it to the world but
i would like any anything like like i
felt bad remember that tony shay
uh tony the guy from zappos you know
that's sad it was sad and but when i saw
that i'm like man i wish it didn't go
that way but at the same time like he
would travel with an entourage and i'm
like that is sick as you know the
substance abuse things was bad but
wherever i went i would just say crew
who who's who's coming with and you and
i have a friend uh this guy who started
rent jungle or not rent juggle jungle
scout greg mercer
and he
bought these fancy seats to f1
and i don't know how much it cost but i
bet you this box cost fifty to a hundred
thousand dollars and he was like
um hey do you want do you wanna come
and i just had cheapo tickets and he's
like we took care of everything and i
was like what i was like well how much
is it i'll pay you he goes no no it's
cool man it's fun i like sharon
and he brought me and it was awesome and
he's told me stories about how he takes
people to telly ride just if he's doing
cool [__] he's like hey anyone who wants
to come come with me and it sounds
awesome that's what i want to do
i did i think i've told you this i did
my will like a year ago
and it was kind of like it was surreal i
was like i guess i'm gonna maybe die one
day but then it really inspired me to to
live while i'm here and spend the money
now while i'm here
so even with my brother i'm like do you
want to kill me and get the money now or
can i just give you some of it now
and it's just it's exciting to start
thinking about how to
live like you have the will and like
live like you're dead and enjoy the
money with friends like you're talking
about that's a great way to approach it
do you are you gonna have kids anytime
soon i mean it feels weird making a will
where you gotta like give [__] to your
mom and your brother
yeah my brother has a kid which i was
like that guy's gonna get all this money
like that's crazy it's not even yours
yeah
it's not even minor it's not his like
it's not your kid i mean it just feels
like you're not like you love him but
you're not it's not your your blood or
your you know it is part some blood i
think genetics some uh yeah i think i'll
have kids i mean i maybe i'll go to
sperm bank and just donate a ton and
then each of those kids gets like a mill
maybe they get each one of them gets a
crypto punk
yeah [__]
um
we're going to wrap up here in a minute
but this has been a a meandering episode
i actually think it's going to go over
kind of well i
i i think people are gonna dig it i you
know
i got nothing to say to that i thought
it's interesting i mean
talked about a variety of subjects and
then what what do people want out of the
show why do you think people listen to
something to like entertain like empty
calories frank business advice so
there's a few things one i will say i'm
shocked anyone listens but at this point
we're at
we're at we're we're like over a million
downloads a month now
um which is crazy
so some episodes like 50 60 70 000
downloads which is pretty crazy
um
two
shockingly people find us funny
like that's what the comments say which
amazed me and three i would say
sean's really good i think sean's good i
think a lot of people listen for him
you're good too man you're just a good
follow-on i mean i think what it is is
you're the only ones left podcasting
like everyone gave up like a few years
ago and you're like no one told you
so you kept going it's been so hard it
is hard man but i think that's you know
you forget my mom always says this like
you forget how hard the last lap is
and i think sometimes when you just kind
of push through and you're like oh i
guess that wasn't so hard and the
further away you get from it well is
youtube easier you think
uh
it's hard you could you could what
define easy right is the [__] answer
um yeah
it's challenging and it's in a different
way i think the intimacy of an audience
is really high with podcasts like
they're really spending a lot of time
with you
youtube it's harder to be successful on
it
i think it's harder
i don't know harder
but there is a broader audience
available for you to reach so that's why
i spend all my time so i stopped
podcasting more or less i still have my
show that noah kaden presents but you
know of my content creation audience
building 95 percent of that's in youtube
world it's harder for people to do it
like that you can't just go back it's so
hard it's so i know you put out a video
like
well all of it takes forever it's just
like i think you know the [__]
answers find the thing that you could
work forever on
my video that i i made my first youtube
video i'm gonna start doing one a week
it got 3000 views baby
oh which one the drinking one
no the um
real estate one about my project how
many 4.3 000 views
2.4 000 that's good man look dude i
didn't even remove the descript logo at
the bottom because it cost 25 and i was
like i don't know if i'm gonna even do
this next next month did you edit
yourself
yeah good for you there's there's no
editing they're just like i spliced
clips together
how was it for you how was this
experience doing it it sucks i hated it
but um
uh it's it's cool to see the result like
i understand why you know who the best
at here's the best youtuber i think out
right now he's he's out of this world
nick bear
oh dude love nick bear nick bear's the
best youtuber i've been seeing lately
the other day he put out basically a
documentary and he's doing like one or
two a week
um he did a documentary on the leadville
100 this 100-mile race he did nick
bear's the most impressive youtuber i've
seen lately do you agree with have you
had him on your show
yeah but it was a little bit more it was
before he was really famous
nick is just dope man he's just like a
good dude and like you when you find out
he like started his business at 4 00 a.m
when he was in on and on base in korea
he's like damn that like
i'm not surprised when people are
successful i'm like oh yeah you put in
the work and you stuck with it for a
long period of time that's it did you
meet him in person
yeah it's awesome is he just yoked
yeah yeah i'm gonna i think i'm gonna
work out with them next month or in
january
oh you should stop with them
yeah i think part of it is like you know
i've said this before it's like most of
my net worth is from who i know
and so nick i gotta meet him and help
out help his stuff helps me out
um but there's certain people that you
see like nick that you're just like yeah
man i hope you get there and he's
getting there obviously but there's just
people you want to see succeed i think
people don't want to see me and you
succeed sam but they they just can't
stop us
some do some are like noah why do you
say that i want to see you succeed but i
think it's just like no
you you and i are very punchable
that's why we do boxing
we let other people have a chance to
punch us let me ask you a last question
what what what can i learn from nick
from you knowing him
oh i would definitely have him back on
the show
um
when he was on the show he was super
like
almost naive like it felt like like not
but that not a bad way where he was like
learning as we were talking to him like
he acted like he was unaware of certain
things and i'm like dude i know you know
about this but you're just like a sponge
and you just are trying to get me to
tell you everything so you know he was
just interesting he just felt like a
student
yeah that's i mean it could be his
i don't know if he's trying to be
strategic about that i think that's
interesting
um
i don't know i i guess with nick i'm
impressed his evolvement from like
someone who was a marine or i think he
was a ranger
to a business operator also he's kind of
in a to some extent commoditized space
right like the sugar powder yeah the
powder that get everyone gets from the
same place but you put a different
sticker on it i think i've been
impressed specifically with nick how he
evolved from like uh you know i'll be
straight like a meathead jock lifter to
like one a content creator at like an
elite level from the storytelling and i
think it's just his physical fitness is
really well-rounded so well-rounded man
who on earth can weigh 195 pound and you
know squat 500 pounds and run a
three-hour marathon it's so interesting
there's a lot of there's a lot of good
youtubers out there man it's just
unbelievable how much great content is
being created who do you like we'll wrap
up with that who do you like
uh let's look at my homepage so
obviously noah kagan colin and samir are
studs i i love colin smear oh dude you
know who's the best
andrew callahan channel five he was the
all gas no brakes
wait what
oh he is dude watch the check bake so
channel five with andrew callahan
uh watch the um
watch the pickup artist boot camp or
check oh
yeah this guy he used to be part of like
a business that he bailed on
he was i think for vice or something
like that all gas no breaks yeah yeah
he's sick colin and samir are sick on on
just specifically on creators
um i like watching dude my weird freaky
fetish lately is just i love watching
like outdoor survival
same which ones
uh who's the guy in ohio dave canterbury
so i watched dave canterbury actually
just writing all these down dave cannon
barry yeah dave canterbury architectural
digest is gangster i love seeing like
celebrity homes
do you like primitive technologies uh i
think i've seen them i think i'm pretty
aggressive on unsubscribing for some
reason i unsubscribe from them i see
primitive dude i'm looking at dave
cantonbury he looks amazing this is
exactly how i want my guys to look have
you watched the show alone
no
oh oh on hulu yes
have you met like with the guy that
looks like uh like he like he's wearing
like bear skin around he looks like a
native american the white dude but he's
like i actually don't know where he is
and there's another
caves of missouri uh there's a bunch of
weird-ass people in there but dude it's
epic
so i i definitely would recommend alone
so i like all the survival stuff from
that i watch a lot dude this is the
weirdest one i watch a lot of squash
videos i probably watch like like it's
on right now
watch this while you're talking to me
sam
i have it on in the background like
hydraulic hydraulic press no squash like
the game like the british gabe
why are you watching that
i just leave it on it's just like white
noise i put on the background so i watch
a lot of that on youtube
that's kind of a lot of that's the main
things like outdoor survival
architecture of course neville
and uh yeah that's about it
all right well
ben what do we think
i'll tell you some i'll tell you another
good book i read man i'll tell a weird
one that people have dude i've been
reading all crime books so like like the
real murder mystery
well yeah i like that but like i just
like one on 9 11
um
another one
favorite book this year
favorite book this year okay you're
gonna like this one because you do this
it's called travels with charlie in
search of america john steinbeck wrote
it in 1930. and john cybeck you know
famous author
and he was like you know i live in cape
cod and i'm rich now i'm in my 60s i've
been reading writing about middle
america for the past 50 years and i'm so
out of touch right now and he just
drives his uh pickup truck around
america and just talks to people and
writes about it and it's amazing do you
know who lieutenant dan is in um forrest
gump yeah yeah he's the narrator of the
audiobook
so
that's a good one and then empire the
summer moon you'd like that one it's
about oh i heard that one what's the
comanche indians
um and they're they're just nutty like
the texans were evil and the indians
were evil to each other uh the indians
and the uh uh
texans were just like it's about how
they just destroyed each other and then
finally the operator which is basically
the guy who killed bin laden and he like
tells the story of finding bin laden and
that was is that good some of these
military books were kind of weak
not man that one was pretty spectacular
yeah i mean he talks about like finding
he he goes in depth about
hunting down bin laden and and shooting
him in the head like it's intense all
right a few questions here one do you
get books from the library at all no but
either you or neville have been bragging
about how amazing it is dude i'm a huge
library guy there's a chrome extension
called library
uh it's called library extension that'll
show you if you can get digital or audio
books for free
and it shows you when you go to amazon
so you just put in austin library dude i
use all the time how do they make money
i just donated i don't know how they
actually make money
okay uh but thank you for those books
dude yeah library extension you just add
the austin library
uh one book i read recently dude that is
so good i think you really enjoy it it's
called free country
it's two guys in europe who backpack who
try to go from the bottom of uk to the
top of uk biking and they just start in
their underwear that's all they start
with
is it amazing wow what
yeah so they start at the bottom of the
uk in their underwear
that's it and they have to get to the
top of uk on bike in three years it's
really good it got like crazy good
reviews audio book or download
or how do you look for normal i think
the audio book is good dude
all right i think i got it at the
library for free oh and it's on kindle
unlimited it's free on kindle
dude hell yeah
all right i'm i'm gonna do that any
other ones
uh that one was awesome i really enjoyed
that
i didn't know if you wanted more
yeah dude we're reading the same travel
stuff so i'll give you another one then
um
little golden america in the 1930s
two russian journalists from the ussr
were welcomed into america and they just
traveled for uh four months all over
america and they're like you know it's
pretty crazy in america and they just
like you just explain from their
perspective what america is about
they're like in america everyone's so
optimistic for example we met these guys
it's cool and it's
no one knows about it in america but
it's one of the most popular books in
russia
in russia you book read you
uh
uh what else oh dude there's some other
good ones do you read about the dude you
know ryan holliday's book list is really
good uh his email list his email list he
just recommends books i don't know how
he could he consumes so much
i don't know dude he's like audiobooks
it's like 10 a month
there's no way he he does an audio book
no i think he reads he's probably like
it has to be paper and if it's not this
like certain density of organic paper i
won't read it he once said if you're not
taking notes then you're not reading
effectively i think that's true
yeah but that's like i mean i'm not
gonna take notes on like killing up bin
laden
i don't think but most of the books on
kindle are physical i either highlight
and then i'll reread them yeah but dude
if i'm just listening to like a book
like about these guys walking around
their underwear trying to like get from
place to place i'm not gonna like you
know or like fight club i'm not gonna
like write notes
any other ones
um
dude trevor noah's book i was like i
don't care about that guy everyone talks
about that book
it's it's just a really well written
book
well it's like david goggins book i'm
like all right david you're gonna yell
at me you're really hardcore i get it
you could do push-ups or pull-ups that's
great his book if you haven't read
david's like everyone talked about it
it's honestly a phenom one it's very
well written and two it's just a great
story it's just the audiobook is cool
too
yeah him the wright brothers i got that
dude oh i read that one recently amazing
that was awesome i drove to dayton ohio
after i read it because it was so good
oh that's good did you read million
little pieces
no what's that one i actually think
you'll like that one it's about drug
addiction
no but it's a true story that's the
crazy part
okay i really enjoyed that these are
just ones from this year
all right i'm gonna wait i think this
guy james frey
million little pieces didn't he
isn't he famous for a bunch of stuff
yeah he actually wrote a few other books
and then there's some like drama about
him
oh uh they say that he lied about his
book my my uh yeah the
apparently he uh
it's made up
there's debate about that so
it seems like for the most part a lot of
it is not made up and there's just a few
pieces that are yeah i remember this
because he went on oprah years and years
ago and there was this big controversy
well so she talks [__] on him and then
she actually apologized i believe
because i got you after you read the
book you're like is this real or not
real i can't believe it that's how crazy
it is yeah
all right i'm going to read it this is
good this is the best part i'm going to
read all these things i mean i i could i
try to walk a lot so i listen to all
these audio books so i'm gonna i'm gonna
uh download this one a million little
pieces i'm gonna get the uh the guys
doing their underwear thing and i
already installed the library extension
bro game over come on this little gold
in america do they have an audio book or
just paperback uh you could do a
paperback or you can um
there's free pdfs online did you see the
description of it it's interesting
there's like no reviews of it but in the
first page they go we translated this
into russia and yet no one or into
english and yet no one in america knows
about this however in russia everyone
reads this book in schools like this is
like the kids summer reading for schools
it's like very very very popular
um
do you see it
yeah how did you hear about this
goodreads recommended it to me when i
was reading the in search of america uh
the john steinbeck book i loved that
that was one of the best like i it was
like
i got addicted to that it randomly
popped up on things recommended and it
had five out of five reviews five out of
five stars on on
goodreads and it had like three thousand
reviews but when i googled it i couldn't
find a thing about it so i was like this
is kind of intriguing
did you look at it on goodreads uh i do
not like anything it's so funny
goodreads i saw someone talk about this
maybe it's you it's like the site that
hasn't been updated from like 1960 but
it's still dope it's still like a
there's like there's nothing better yet
it's badass uh the guy who started it
spoke at hazelcon his name's otis
chandler and his grandpa started the la
times and otis sold to amazon for like a
billion dollars i think either
i think it was a billion or a hundred
million but he sold it to him like
10 years ago or something like that so
we just knocked it out the park do you
ever you ever blown away by like how
much awesome books are out there that we
don't even know of like this book
existed i've never [__] heard of it
and it's gotten reviews i'm like i did
not know that
yeah and i've always thought i want to
read all this but then you know i
started thinking
one time i i listened to like thinking
real rich
on audiobook and i loved the narrator
and i was like i don't remember those
narrators or the the audio guy i want to
remember his voice because he's so good
and i looked at what else he had done
and he's read like a thousand self-help
books and i'm like wait a minute
you've read all these and you're still
[__] making 50 bucks an hour reading
these damn books what the hell man this
is not effective and so after that i i
almost quit reading business book or
self development books entirely yeah
it's just boring i'd rather read like
biographies or like i'm reading this
book this running book right now out of
thin air
the best right
i just started it's really interesting
i've been liking i guess outdoor
activity books so well out of thin air
that's not that's a different one wait
out of thin air oh you're thinking of um
the one about the guy in alaska
who what's out of thin air oh it's about
kenya
yeah this guy like goes and runs with
kenyans
i think into thin air the john krakauer
one which is also awesome but okay
someone gifted me this out of thin air
book and i wasn't sure if it was that
good is it amazing so far pretty
interesting i mean the i'd go read free
country that one is like i didn't want
to read it because i didn't want it to
be over
all right i'll read it all right i gotta
rock this was good
[Music]
you